okay so thank you for joining us
um my name is scott soderling
and um i'm the cso and founder of
kashtag biosciences i also have research
laboratory at duke university
so what i'm going to talk to you about
today is a novel
crispr knock-in technology for the
robust analysis
of cells and cells within tissues
and i think probably as all of you
appreciate
the analysis of endogenous protein
localization function and dynamics
is really fundamental to the study of
all cells
and is integral to both academic as well
as translational and
industry-based research so today
uh to cover this new technology
i'm going to go through several
different considerations in this slide
deck
so first i'm going to tell you about
this new crispr
cast 9 based approach called homology
independent
universal genome engineering also
abbreviated as huge so i'll just refer
to that as huge throughout the rest of
the talk but that's what it stands for
so i'll tell you a little bit about how
this new technology works
and some of its advantages to other
existing technologies
i'm then going to quickly cover through
some of the considerations that you
might want to
think about and go through as you're
considering
a variety of different types of knock-in
experiments using crispr cast 9
and how these can be addressed using
this new approach
i'll next then jump into examples
of seven different applications that are
quite diverse
as examples of how you can possibly use
huge uh to advance your own research
and then finally we'll go through some
of the validation data
talking about off targets efficiencies
cell types and protein types
that this new method can be used for
so most genetics research workflows
start with a variety of kind of
large-scale
experiments to then quickly narrow in
onto
targets of interest so one example of
this
is an active area of research that's
been active for several decades now
which is the genetics of human patients
that have been diagnosed with a variety
of
disorders you have a genetic basis and
so by
a high throughput sequencing or
genome-wide sequencing
mutations can be identified that are
potentially pathogenic
then lead to hypothesis that can then be
further tested
another entry point for this for these
types of experiments
is omics analysis and so
omics analysis a good example of this
would be proteomics
or another example could be metabolomics
proteomics is actually one type of
analysis
that i utilize quite a bit in my own
research laboratory at duke university
and we use proteomic approaches in order
to identify
proteins that are enriched in particular
parts of neurons within brain tissue
as an entry point to understanding how
these neurons function
to guide and modulate a wide variety of
diverse behaviors and
after identifying proteins or genes of
interest
either through these larger scale types
of
screens often researchers then want to
use
a quick genetic screen further genetic
screen to narrow down on these large
numbers of potential genes of interest
or proteins of interest
and often this is achieved through
crispr based knockout screens
once these genes of interest or proteins
have been narrowed down
then another common step in most
research
workflows is to then further
characterize
these genes of interest or proteins
using um
crispr knock-in technologies and this is
a
an area that has really advanced very
quickly
in the last five years and really this
is
taken over our ability to
localize proteins from either in cells
or in tissues so that we can then better
understand
their function and also
perform functional analysis so that we
can phenotype
what these proteins or genes of interest
are really important for
and cycle back to the entry point that
we started at
which was to generate a hypothesis given
our specific research question
the last two steps which are the crisper
knock-in for characterization and
functional analysis
are two steps that really became
bottlenecks in my own research
laboratory as we identified hundreds of
proteins
through proteomic datasets and we really
realized that we needed higher
throughput technologies that allow us to
do this type of crispr knock-in analysis
and functional analysis
and this led to the development in our
laboratory
of the new technology that's now being
marketed through kastag biosciences
so this is just a quick overview of how
this new technology works
i'll cover uh some of the details of how
this new technology works
in just a couple of slides in general
um this new technology or homology
independent universal genome engineering
used as a proprietary two vector system
the first vector is the targeting vector
and this is similar to
uh all other vectors that are used in
any type of
crispr cas9 based approach so this
targeting vector expresses a guide rna
that is specific for your gene of
interest and guides cast 9
to that genetic low size so that it
creates a double-stranded break
which is schematicized by the strand of
nucleic acid
falling apart with a break in the middle
once this double stranded break is has
been introduced into your gene of
interest exactly and precisely where you
want to
position it we then have a second
vector type called the payload vector
and this is actually quite unique i'll
cover this in just a couple of minutes
but these payload vectors can
encode any functional recombinant dna
sequence that you would like to deliver
to your gene of interest
referred to as the payload the nice
thing about this
is is that these payloads are agnostic
uh to either the species or to the gene
of interest so
the payload vectors uh that have been
developed at kastech biosciences
can be used in both for instance both
mouse as well as
human genomes
and in addition to that individual
payloads can be used across multiple
different genes of interest so it makes
it very easy
to utilize and in um
as a consequence of this we only need to
uh
develop payloads that are specific for
one of
uh three reading frames at either the
n-terminus
or the c-tremendous of where you would
like to modify your protein
so the consequences is that with a
with a simplified six vector payload
system
we can essentially cover all proteins
encoded in both mouse
and human genomes as well as other
genomes as well
so the modularity of of these payloads
because
they are agnostic either to the species
or gene of interest
has allowed for the creation of several
payload
vectors that can be used with any guide
on direct to direct their insertion into
a gene of interest
with different types of functions so the
first
payload vector type is called epitag
this payload vector delivers into the
gene of interest
an antibody epitope tag this is actually
quite useful because a lot of times
in biomedical research we're faced with
trying to understand the function or
characterize further a protein of
interest
however there aren't really high quality
antibodies
that exist for for following up and
localizing these proteins of interest
so instead of developing new antibodies
based on purified protein
we essentially have flipped the process
on its head
and we've taken a sequence that encodes
a short amino acid sequence
for which we already have an antibody
that's highly energetic
and is highly validated and so we can
insert this antibody epitope tag
directly into your protein of interest
and this is called epitag
we also have floor tag this can insert
larger payloads for instance green
fluorescent protein a red fluorescent
protein
so that not only can you localize your
proteins but you can also follow them in
real time
to image their dynamics as they exist
in the cell and then finally the third
payload
vector marketed by kastag is called
disrupt tag this encodes
for an antibody epitope that is
specifically designed to alter your
protein functions so this can be used in
two different ways and i'll show you
later in the talk examples of each of
these but for disrupt tag
you can essentially use this either for
structure structure function analysis
to either truncate your endogenous
protein of interest
at different places and mark the protein
containing that truncation with the
antibody epitope tag
or you can place it very early on in the
gene of interest
to disrupt the expression of the entire
protein and mark those cells
that contain that disruptive insertion
so these are very useful for studying
protein function
okay so here's some more specifics of
exactly how this works
so for the targeting vector
we have a gene-specific guide rna which
i mentioned
um directs the cleavage
in this case i'm showing the cleavage at
the c-terminus of your gene of interest
right before the stop codon in the open
reading frame for your
protein of interest so the gs
guide rna is the gene-specific guide rna
and we package these vectors into
adeno-associated virus and i'll talk
about some of the unique features
of utilizing an associated viruses in
the workflows
in order to utilize this new technology
this then directs the cleavage the
double-stranded break in your
goi or gene of interest this
targeting vector is then paired with a
unique
payload vector this payload vector is
self-cleaving and so the way that this
works is that the payload vector
also expresses a donor-specific guide
rna
that recognizes a donor recognition
sequence that and this donor recognition
sequence
flanks either side of the payload of
of foreign dna sequence that you would
like to insert in
these donor specific guide rnas have
been carefully chosen
so that they're inert to
either human or mouse genomes so these
guide rnas don't recognize anything
in either of those genomes but instead
they specifically recognize
the payload vector cleave the payload
out of the vector so they can then
efficiently insert
into your gene of interest and in cash
tag we've identified
the genetic rules that are required in
order to utilize this
such that these payloads can insert in
in frame and into any gene of interest
so the upside of this is that instead of
having to
um specify unique donor vectors
for each payload and for each gene of
interest
we can a large scale generate libraries
of gene specific guide rna targeting
vectors
to your genes of interest to label your
proteins of interest
and then combine that with pre-made
payloads and these payloads are
essentially plug and play
so in this schematic i've got payload a
b and c
and these payloads all can insert into
diverse
genes of interest once they've been
unlocked and opened up
by the double-stranded break encoded by
the gene-specific
targeting vector this then allows a
rapid and versatile modification of
endogenous proteins
for a wide variety of applications
including localization mapping
as well as functional manipulation
okay so that's a little background about
this new technology homology independent
universal genome engineering now i'm
going to cover a couple of the important
considerations that should be thought
through
in order to apply this new technology to
your own research
so the first consideration that you
should think about
is are the specifics of your gene of
interest
and the protein that it encodes so you
need to think about
uh you need to know something about
where your protein of interest may be
expressed
so that you're using the appropriate
cell type or tissue type
in order to apply this technology we
also need to know
a little bit about something about the
protein of interest
in other words will this protein
tolerate insertions or fusions either at
the n-terminus
or at the c-terminus and that's really
unique for each protein
our team of scientists can also help you
predict
this as well if you're not if you're not
exactly sure
i'm not going to cover those in detail
but i'm instead going to talk more about
the crisper knocking
approaches considerations that you
should go through and i'm going to cover
the repair mechanisms
the delivery method of getting this into
the cells
and then the desired payloads for your
specific knock-ins
so there are several different repair
mechanisms that have evolved
and have been utilized for crispr
knock-in approaches
probably currently today the most
common repair mechanism is hdr or
homology directed repair
knock-in this
this approach has some advantages
as well as several disadvantages
so in general homology directed repair
only works in dividing cells
this is not the preferred repair pathway
following the double-stranded break
within cells and so the efficiency
or the the percent of repairs following
a double-stranded break
that utilizes hdr is estimated to be
somewhere around 10 percent
because hdr and i'll go through this in
a little more detail in the next slide
but because
hdr is using homology
this necessitates that each donor vector
is unique um to the uh gene of interest
and the insertion efficiency is
typically less than one percent
it's it's is typically somewhere around
point one percent
however in some cases it can be anywhere
up to
5 so the efficiencies overall of
insertion are fairly low
the advantage is is that when it does
work you can get scarless integration so
you can have your recombinant dna
seamlessly integrate into
the dna sequence that you're targeting
of course the disadvantages though
which is a pretty large payoff
trade-off is in the efficiency as well
as the throughput because you have to
make a unique donor vector for each type
the other type of repair mechanism that
occurs in cells following
double-stranded breaks is non-homology
end-joining and this works both in
dividing cells as well as non-dividing
cells
and is the preferred pathway for repair
following these double-stranded breaks
in cells
so more recently researchers have begun
to
realize that non-homology and joining
can also be used for very efficient
knock-in
using crispr cas9 technology and this is
actually
the repair pathway that homology
independent universal genome engineering
are huge utilizes
and so the advantage of this is because
there are no homology arms
the um insertion efficiency is
relatively high
anywhere from 20 to 30 percent
the it's highly uh
it enjoys a high throughput because you
don't have to design
custom or boutique domino directors for
each gene of interest
it's very easy to utilize the
disadvantage which i'll go through in
the next slide
and comparing in more detail hdr
non-homology and joining
is that you can get both scarred
in addition to the scarless integration
and so that's been considered
a disadvantage but i'll cover why
probably it's not that
as big of a disadvantage as previously
was thought
so why use non-homology end joining
rather than
hdr so i mentioned that homology
directed repair so in this example what
i'm
showing you is an example of where you
might
want to insert something such as green
fluorescent protein
into your gene of interest using
homology arms on either side
now these homology arms the length of
these homology arms can be quite
variable depending on the type of
insertion you want to do
for something that's relatively large
such as green fluorescent protein
typically you would want to have your
homology arms somewhere between
500 base pairs to 1kb so a lot of labor
has to go into cloning on these homology
arms on either side of your
green fluorescent protein the hdr also
only occurs um in dividing cells and
that's because
it's operational in in two phases of the
cell cycle both
the s phase as well as g2 and so if
you'd like to use knock-in technology in
primary non-dividing cells or directly
in tissue
this just simply won't work the end
result however is that you can get
scarless
integration and so
down at the bottom i've schematized a
protein of interest
that's been fused to green fluorescent
protein
however this is typically somewhere in
the range of one percent to 0.1 percent
in some cases with very small inserts
this can be as
is as high as 5 but the majority of the
cases are the protein alone which is
schematicized next to it without the gfp
fusion in contrast non-homology
n-joining is not limited to
either the s or g-2 phase of the cell
cycle
and therefore it can operate in both
dividing as well as non-dividing cells
in this case i'm showing a green
fluorescent protein you'll note that
there are no
arms of homology on either side
so this can just directly insert into
your gene of interest
somewhere between 30 to 40 percent of
the time
that you have the insertion you can have
scarless integration just like you have
with
hdr the rest of the cases
you can have small insertions or
deletions
at the junction between your gene of
interest
and from in this case green fluorescent
protein
if these indels insertions or deletions
if they're in frame
then you still have a a functional
fusion between in this case green
fluorescent protein
and your protein of interest and this
occurs
uh the majority of the time and so uh
the advantage of using or leveraging
non-homology and joining one of the
advantages
is that you also enjoy a great gain in
the efficiency in the number of
percentage of cells that are effectively
labeled
in the cases where there's a
scarred insertion with an insertion or
deletion that throws
the subsequent gfp out of frame
or for instance an epitope tag
those out of frame infusions are no
longer detected as functional
fluorescent protein or epitope tag
so essentially those events are dark and
they're not part of the analysis
in the subsequent functional analysis
okay so the next consideration to think
about beyond the repair
mechanism that you're going to utilize
is the delivery mechanism
and so uh for huge for cash tag
biosciences we use technology viruses
but there are other
mechanisms that can utilize as well so
the first is electroporation
electroporation uh generating electrical
pulse to deliver
your molecules of interest into the cell
electroporation can occur with a high
efficiency
if the protocol for the electroporation
has been optimized for the specific
cell type that you're utilizing the
negative side of electroporation is that
it can impact cell variability so
in many of these cases at least 50
percent of the cells
may be killed during the electroporation
event
this is generally limited to in vitro
cells and culture this is where is found
most of its use
i would note that there are some cases
where you can apply electroporation
in in vivo however the majority of the
cases are used in vitro
and of course the biggest downside of
electroporation
is that it can require expensive
equipmentation
as well as extensive optimization for
your cell type of interest
the next delivery mechanism is are
liposomes
and there are commercial kits for a
variety of different types of liposomes
so they're quite easy to use um this
also has
uh can have impacts to cell very
viability
depending on the cell type and the like
personal issues
um it's also limited to in vitro
delivery
for the most part and it's limited
limited cell types
that you can use liposomes to deliver
your
crispr reagents to and of course the
efficiency is much lower than that of
electroporation
and then finally viral delivery is
another option and in this case we
utilize adeno-associated virus
the reason for this is that
adeno-associated viruses
depending on the serotype that you're
using can have very broad tropism
so there's no optimization that's
required
you essentially sprinkle the virus onto
your cells of interest
or inject it into your tissue of
interest and
because of its broad tropism it will
infect
these cells at a very high efficiency so
the transduction efficiency is typically
very high
in vitro this can approach 100 percent
it's gentle on the cell so
cell viability is very high the only
downside
for adeno-associated viruses that
require some specialized knowledge
for the viral purification in order to
achieve high titers
however this is something that is taken
care of by kastech biosystems
when we deliver these reagents to your
laboratory
so how does uh huge work in the
discovery
typical discovery workflow so the first
is
come to us with a hypothesis so you have
your gene of interest
your protein of interest that you would
like to follow up on
contact our team of scientists they'll
help you select the locus
and select the insertion site in order
to make the fusion or the knock and into
your protein of interest
our team then does the computational
design of the guide rnas
and prepares those for you they package
these into high tighter
adeno associated viruses deliver these
to your laboratory where you then
initiate your own experiment either in
vitro or in vivo
so here you typically are going to
sprinkle the the adeno-associated virus
onto your directly onto your samples
or inject it directly into tissue
incubate this anywhere from seven to ten
days to let the virus transduct your
cells
for the incorporation of the fusion
protein or the fusion into your protein
of interest
and then follow on with the typical
workflows that you have
for data analysis and hopefully uh
future breakthrough
so here's what the kits actually look
like so i just covered
the services that we include so that's
the guide design and selection
the aav packaging these are pre-mixed
for you so that all you have to do is
take it out of these tubes and sprinkle
it onto your cells or inject it into
your tissue
each kit comes with a um
guide rna actually has two different
guide rnas
that's pre-mixed with your donor of
interest so you tell us if you want
how you want to label your protein of
interest we'll give you the appropriate
donor
it comes with a positive control virus
for a known and validated protein that
works in your species
of interest about 50 microliters of high
tider virus
and the titer here is 10 to the 13th so
this is a quite a high purified
titer that can be used even directly
from vivo use and this 10 to the 13th
just remember that number when i get to
the validation later in the talk
okay so that's some of the
considerations um
and how this technology works what are
some of the applications that you might
want to think about using this for so
here i'm going to cover
um seven different examples of
applications spanning everything from
microscopy
western blotting to tr protein
truncation studies
um i won't mention uh proteomics
although you can use this for proteomics
since you're labeling your proteins of
interest so we have used this for
immunoprecipitations
followed by mass spectrometry and then
also cell line creation
okay so the first example of an
application is
antibody driven applications and this is
really what drove the development of
of huge in my own laboratory where we
had novel proteins of interest
but the antibodies that we bought uh on
the antibody market
uh had lots of cross reactivity and just
simply didn't work
so in this case uh where you in this
example
we've incorporated an h a epitope tag
that was directly inserted into in this
case a beta 3 tubulin
so that when beta 3 endogenous beta 3
tubulin is expressed it now has this ha
epitope tag that we can
use to detect it with aha antibody
here's an example of sequencing across
the junction site
for the mouse beta 3
genetic locus and you can see from the
chromatograms
a perfect insertion of a tag of that
remaining part of the donor recognition
sequence where this has been cleaved out
of the payload vector
along with the h a payload
that's been inserted into beta 3 tubulin
now i should note
i should mention that we've designed
this epitope our epitope tag
kits and we have several different
epitopes such that in either orientation
that inserts into
it generates a functional um a
functional effusion with the epitope of
interest and so it's in dual orientation
so following this insertion here's a
western blot of the
labeled neuro in this case these were
primary neurons
the ha epitope tag versus negative
control cells
and you can see that by western blood
analysis in the green that there's a
single
h amino reactive protein of the correct
size for beta 3 tubulin
and the loading controls of gap dh are
in red
below that here's an example of what
this actually looks like in the dish and
really the first time that we saw this
this really uh blew us away
uh so here you see in the green um the
amino
staining for h a immunoreactivity and
you can see
a large number of neurons now that have
been labeled for beta-3 tubulin
this works not only for epifluorescence
imaging
and confocal imaging but also works for
super-resolution imaging so it's
multiple modalities of imaging that
these epitope tags can be used for
and then the bottom example is
stimulated
depletion excitation and depletion or
stead super resolution imaging
where you can see individual fibers of
tubulin
and a dendrite from one of these labeled
neurons and in the red
you can see these beautiful synapses
that are viewed as puncta along
on the dendritic shaft so one of the
advantages because these pillows don't
really
um they're agnostic to the gene of
interest
they'll insert into any any gene of
interest where we supply these
double-stranded breaks
is that you can actually mix these
several different epitopes into a single
tube
along with the targeting vector
virus and in a single experiment
um incubate in this example neurons with
three different epitope tags
so you can rapidly optimize what type of
fusion
uh your protein tolerates and what type
of um
in this case epitope antibody works best
for immunostaining your cells or tissue
of interest so this is an example
of cultured neurons where you can see
with three different colors we've
detected
the three different epitope tags that
we've simultaneously introduced
into the kind of mosaically into these
neurons of interest
and here's an example where we've also
done this by injecting it directly
into cas9 transgenic pups
let them grow up and then section
coronal sections um through the brain
and you can see that kind of this
beautiful labeling
uh throughout the brain of two different
epitope texts that we've mixed
simultaneously and i'll
i'll show some higher uh resolution
images of that in just a minute
the next application so that's for
looking at cells
either in culture or in tissue
statically what if you want to look at
them dynamically and so in this case
because of the high efficiency of
non-homology and joining the huge
leverages we can also have high
efficiencies
and start even larger inserts such as
fluorescent proteins
this is an example where we've used our
dual vector system to insert in
a red fluorescent protein into a
mitochondrial
um gene of interest
to label the mitochondria and these
primary neurons
and in just a second you're going to see
this movie play
it's going to loop through it four
different times
okay so hopefully you saw there um
you can easily image the dynamics of
your proteins
of interest in this case red fluorescent
protein
labeling mitochondria the next example
is disrupt tag here we've used this
to look at the parts of beta force
spectrum
this is a protein that's localized to
the axonal initial segment of primary
neurons
and here we're using structure function
analysis at the endogenous protein
in order to determine which part of the
protein is important for its
localization
so here we've either epitope tagged it
at the very c-terminus
with an aha epitope tag or truncated it
internally here are the results
following that
so here you can see on the
far end the full-length tagged protein
localizes uh tightly to these axonal
initial segments
if we truncate in and we loop off this
plexus homology domain
which is a membrane binding domain this
in the endogenous
beta 4 spectrum is still localized at
the actual axonal initial segment
if we target however the spectrum
repeats
internally for truncation what we see
now is that the protein becomes diffused
so we can rapidly determine
which of the protein domains are
important for the localization of the
endogenous protein as
is it exists in primary cells and here's
just a western blood analysis
showing the serial truncation in the uh
in the two middle lanes of of the
truncated protein
by western blot analysis versus negative
control
okay the other uh use that that
we're quite excited about is using this
to generate
rapidly diverse types of cell lines and
so in this
example what we've done is we've labeled
a protein
involved in endocytosis called clathrin
with gfp so we've labeled the endogenous
classroom protein with gfp
we used a huge to label these cells in
vitro
then we fact sorted these cells and
within two weeks from
the generation of the guide rna and the
cloning to the fact sorting we're able
to select for stable cell lines encoding
a functional
gfp fusion protein with this
endocytic protein clathrin so this
actually worked quite well
for rapidly generating a wide variety of
different
labeled proteins within your cell types
of interest stably
another example is rerouting your
proteins of interest so that they're no
longer localized to where they normally
are localized to this can be used for
both
gain of function as well as loss of
function studies
so in this case what we've done is we've
taken an ha epitope tag and we've fused
this to a nuclear localization signal
and we've inserted this into a
cytoskeletal protein called arp2
now in primary neurons r2 is highly
localized
in these puncta which correspond to
uh dendritic spines it's synapses and
you can see that in the top
blown up sample we've simultaneously
incubated these neurons
with a different version so in the in
the top and the green version
is just an h a tag so you can see for a
mig tag so you can see where the
endogenous protein is localized
in the red version we've put in this h a
nuclear localization signal and here you
can see now
all of the signal is localized to the
nucleus as the endogenous protein is
dragged away
from where it normally resides which are
in the green dots out in the synapses
finally um the last application is for
many proteins of interest
since since you want to study them at
the endogenous level
none of these are expressed at very low
levels and so
um because of that they can also be
difficult
to resolve based on imaging even with
the insertion of a single
antigen epitope tag and so here
uh we've leveraged the ability to insert
larger
inserts this is something called
spaghetti monster and here we've ins and
so the spaghetti monster is essentially
a dark version of gfp
and the spaghetti monster actually
encodes within the framework of the dark
version of gfp 12 different copies of
the ha epitope tag
so this is a highly antigenic um
insertion so that you can easily detect
even proteins that are expressed at very
low levels
so here are some examples down below
where we've used this to tag
several novel proteins that are
localized at inhibitory synaptic
contacts
in primary neurons i won't go through
the names of these proteins
it doesn't really matter except that
we're labeling these with this highly
antigenic
sequence and then verifying that they do
localize to these types of
inhibitory synapses using a positive
control antibody that we know works
okay so those are some of the
applications that you might want to use
this novel
knock-in technology for and i'd like to
quickly go through some of the
validation
of these types of experiments so the
first the first question
um that you should always ask when using
crispr cas9
based approaches are what are the off
and so we've looked at this in multiple
different ways
i'll show you data from one of them so
in this case
we've predicted the the predicted off
target
potential cleavage sites
based on the guide rnas for labeling our
genes of interest
so and based on these predicted off
target sites we designed
specific primers that would amplify
the genetic loci of these off-target
sites
if our donor vector inserted into those
off-target
sites so in the top two panels from this
western blot so here
on the left hand side in panel d i'm
showing the predicted off target sites
for in this case this was an example
where we labeled
a voltage-gated sodium channel
with an h a epitope tag in
panel e i'm showing western blood
analysis where we looked at
um basically this is a um
genotyping assay genotyping for the off
target insertion
in the top panel and the middle panel
are pcr reactions to look for
either the forward or the reverse
integration of this h a epitope tag
the first lane there is the on target
insertion so you see that these
primers very
robustly detect the insertion that's
correct
the rest of the west or the one sorry
not western block
the rest of the gel uh is showing an
image
standing for dna if there were any
off-target insertion sites and here you
can see that there are no off-target
insertion sites at the predicted
off-target sites and down below
we've used these primers to pcr across
the junction as a positive control and
you can see that all of these work
we've also done genome-wide analysis
looking for any possible off-target
insertions
and what we found is that these
off-target events are very rare so less
than three percent of cells have any
off-target
insertion and of the off-target
insertions
that we've been able to identify all of
these were in non-coding sequences and
so they weren't functional in-frame
fusions
the other note that i'll make on off
target effects
is that in labeling experiments for
for knock-in type experiments
each cell is an independent event
and so if your labeling is consistent
across multiple different cell types
that's
generally going to be the correct um
fusion and so you
you know in a way you almost have an a
built in
built-in experiment to verify
independently
multiple different events that the
labeling is effective
and robust we've also looked at the
efficiency of insertion by image
analysis in this case we've
targeted two different genes beta for
spectrum as well as this
sodium voltage-dependent sodium channel
and here we've looked at different viral
titers and how different viral titers of
the
targeting and the guide rna and the
donor vector affect the efficiency and
you can see at the highest tire that we
tested
this is 10 to the 11th we get somewhere
between in the middle panels and b
you see that we get 29 to 34 percent so
around
30 percent insertion
efficiency when we supply these
viruses to you we supply them at 10 to
the 13th
we've also looked at the ratio so we've
already optimized the ratio of the guide
aav or the targeting vector av with the
payload aav
and we find that the optimal ratio of
those two viruses together is a one to
one and so that's how we supply it
in the kits that we send
okay so this works for a wide variety of
diverse protein types so this is just
an image example of 12 different
proteins that we designed guides for and
labeled in primary neurons within a week
so this is
quite easy to use and quite rapid
and we've overall we've labeled
cytoskeletal proteins
receptors proteins that mark organelles
so you saw the example of the movie
lighting up mitochondria in real time
nuclear nucleus membrane channels
including that voltage-gated sodium
channel signaling proteins
including kinases proteins involved in
vesicle trafficking
as well as of course unknown proteins
which are some of the more exciting ones
we've also validated this in vivo so
this again is an example of in vivo so
we also see
this was an example where we injected
the
mixed donor as well as the
targeting viruses together into adult
mice
into the cortex and labeled
two different uh genes of interest that
are localized to these axonal initial
segments so either beta4 spectrum
or this voltage-gated sodium channel and
you can see my
marking the endogenous
axonal initial segment with an antibody
specific against beta4 spectrum
versus the ha labeled structure we can
then calculate the efficiency of
integration even in vivo
and again we see around 20 to 30 percent
efficiencies in vehicle using these
viruses
and again um not only can it be
multiplexed in vitro
to optimize the types of sequences that
you might want to fuse with your protein
of interest
in vitro but you can also do this in b
bone so these are some of the pretty
pictures
from the multiplexed of two different
antibody epitope tags both ha as well as
mick
a variety of different cortical
and subcortical structures and you can
see
this was for beta 3 tubulin and so you
can see that
it's quite efficient and really gives a
really beautiful labeling
mosaic labeling even within tissue so
you can rapidly optimize your
experiments in vivo as well
so in conclusion
i hope i hope that you've learned
something about this new technology and
how powerful it can be
how easy it is to deploy we hope uh that
you'll contact
biosciences we would love to hear from
you so that we can help you guide
design guides for your genes of interest
we will send these prepackaged aav for
immediate use we're also open developing
custom payloads so if you don't see a
payload
or a sequence you would like to insert
into your gene of interest on our
website
please contact our sales force or our
technical support team
we would love to work with you to
develop new
payload vectors also if you're
interested in becoming a beta tester
to test new payloads we have several
in-house that are currently being
generated to empower
vivo imaging studies as well as
proteomics if you'd like to become a
beta tester
again please look at our website listed
below as well as contact our sales force
or our technical support team
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention
and um and i'll take questions um
i'll take questions any questions that
are you have from this
presentation